Salut la Team Mentalo, aujourd'hui je suis avec... Céline Holynski !
- Oui c'est moooi !
Elle sait que c'est elle, et vous vous savez déjà que c'est elle, parce qu'on avait déjà fait des vidéos ensemble,
plus précisément une, celle-ci quand on était à Londres au début de l'année.
Tu te souviens ?
- Oh là là!
Ce temps magnifique !
- Pas le même que maintenant ! [rires]
Exactement. On l'a ramené de Londres et on l'a gardé depuis le mois de Janvier.
Faut vraiment qu'on parte ailleurs hein..
Vous la voyez aussi dans le fond de certains Mental Vlog,
on la voit qui disparaît, qui s'en va, ou qui passe derrière une fenêtre.
- Un petit peu comme les spectres finalement !
Il a quelques temps, tu as émis l'envie d'avoir toi aussi un vrai quelque chose pour toi.
- Révolution, rébellion, y'en a marre ! C'est tout bon pour les autres et moi... hein ?
Juste en cobaye ! Eh bah non.
Donc c'est spontanément et avec envie et plaisir que j'ai dit "bah viens on va faire la vidéo du vendredi ensemble".
On fait cette vidéo là ensemble.
Je n'ai pas voulu te mentaliser, parce que j'ai pensé à un petit truc qu'on pourrait faire ensemble dans 6 mois,
je te le dirai tout à l'heure.
C'est une surprise.
Ça fait très longtemps que je n'ai pas fait de magie moi-même sur la chaîne.
Donc je vais te faire un tour avec un petit paquet de cartes, où se trouve des petites cartes.
Et on se demande si je vais dire le mot "petit" à chaque fois que je parle. [rires]
J'ai des cartes avec moi, je vous les fais voir. Je te les fais voir également.
- Oui.
Ça va ?
- Oui je les vois bien ! [rires]
Tu me dis sur tu veux que je recule.
Choisi une carte, celle que tu veux, dans le hasard le plus complet.
Si elle ne te plait pas, tu changes de carte.
Elle te plait ou pas ?
- Oui, elle me plait !
C'est vrai ?
- Oh là là!
Tu la fais bien voir à tout le monde s'il te plait.
Sauf à moi évidemment.
C'est bon ?
- C'est bon !
Et tu la reposes.
Et moi je referme le jeu, j'égalise bien, il n'y a pas de break, de chose comme ça...
C'est bien refermé, ça marche ?
Est-ce que tu te souviens bien de la face de ta carte ?
- Oui !
Est-ce que tu te souviens bien du dos de ta carte ?
- Bah oui...
- Donc c'était un dos comment ?
- Rouge !
En fait je t'avais dit que je te faisais un tour de magie, c'était en fait une petite mentalisation
c'est-à-dire que je voulais te faire voir que les gens ne prêtaient pas attention aux choses.
Et en fait, tu n'as pas prêté attention.
Comme pour toi tous les dos étaient rouges, tu n'as pas fait attention qu'il y avait un dos bleu.
Un dos bleu.
Un seul dos bleu.
Un dos bleu, et un seul dos bleu.
Il n'y a pas deux dos bleu,
il n'y a qu'un seul dos bleu.
Est-ce que tu peux me dire quelle était ta carte avant que je l'a retourne, s'il te plait ?
- Le 7 de trèfle.
Le 7 de trèfle, qui est donc la carte que toi tu avais choisie.
Par contre je t'ai promis un petit tour de magie.
Donc on va essayer de rendre ça un peu plus magique.
Tu peux tendre la main comme ça ?
La propre...?
Non, je rigole !
[rires]
C'est celle-ci qui fini sur ma joue en général.
Tu mets l'autre main, comme ça par au-dessus, pour être sûr que je ne puisse pas prendre la carte.
- Tu ne la saisiras jamais !
Jamais.
Je vais te demander de choisir une carte. Est-ce que tu peux sortir ta troisième main ?
[rires]
Non, cherche pas tu n'en as pas, j'en suis quasiment certain.
Du coup tu vas me dire "stop" quand tu veux.
- Stop !
Tu retiens la carte ?
- Oui.
Vous pourriez répondre quand je parle...
Oui je l'ai vu, et j'en ai rien à faire.
Tu as retenu la carte. Est-ce que tu as retenu le dos de la carte ?
- Ah ! Ne me dis pas qu'il est arc-en-ciel ! [rires]
Alors, non en fait si tu te souviens bien je t'ai fait voir la carte qui se trouvait en-dessous quand tu m'as dit stop
donc on n'a pas pu voir le dos.
Le dos était caché.
Et je peux de toute manière prouver qu'il n'y a pas d'autre dos bleu.
Il n'y a qu'un seul dos bleu.
Et si ça se trouve, tout ce qui s'est passé précédemment
était simplement une illusion, un sentiment de déjà vu.
Peut être que tu n'as jamais eu le 7 de trèfle dans les mains.
Peut être que le 7 de trèfle a toujours eu un dos rouge.
Peut être même qu'il est dans ce jeu là.
Est-ce que tu peux me dire quelle carte tu as vu après ? Ou que tu as cru voir peut être ?
- C'était... le 3 de coeur ?
Le 3 de cœur ? Peut être... je ne sais pas, je ne l'ai pas vu.
Est-ce que toi, tu peux retourner les mains comme ça, et les ouvrir ?
Et à l'intérieur tu as juste une carte, et une seule carte: le 3 de cœur à dos bleu.
Et non un 7 de trèfle.
Merci beaucoup Céline Holynski !
- Elle est là...
Ça va, ça te plait ?
- Mais ouais !
Oh c'est pas mal !
C'est pas mal hein ?
- Ouais c'est bien, c'est bien !
- Oh c'est... c'est comme l'apéro quoi, c'est... tu vois...
C'est comme l'apéro, ça m'a vite saoulé !
[rires]
- Bravo ! [applaudissements]
Mais merci ! Merci beaucoup ! Merci à toi d’être venue te faire mentaliser, ou plutôt magiquer,
ou "mentalgiquer" on va dire !
Je t'ai promis quelque chose c'est que comme ça faisait 6 mois que tu n'étais pas venue sur la chaîne,
je te propose de revenir dans 6 mois.
- Ouais... il faut voir l'agenda.
[rires]
Olala, ça lui donne une envie...
En fait Céline m'a déjà raconté qu'elle est allée voir des hypnothérapeutes.
- Oui.
Des hypnotiseurs, des hypnothérapeutes, c'était pour arrêter de fumer c'est ça ?
- Exactement.
Et ça n'a pas marché ?
Heu... Ça n'a pas franchement marché. J'avais de la peine pour lui,
parce que je n'avais pas suffisamment de réactions, et je sentais qu'il en attendait une
donc je faisais des soubresauts de doigts.
En fait c'est même pire que ça, c'est-à-dire que lui s'est mis à fumer après ça, alors qu'il ne fumait pas du tout au départ.
-C'est ça ! C'est terrible.
Personne n'a jamais réussi à l’hypnotiser, donc je te propose de revenir dans 6 mois sur la chaîne,
et moi j'essayerai de t'hypnotiser.
-Est-ce que je peux signer une clause... enfin je fais pas de trucs louches après ?
Je commence pas à danser la macarena...
Ah oui c'est chelou ça la macarena ?
[rires]
Parce que moi, vu ce que j'ai en tête, la macaréna je trouvais ça plutôt cool en fait !
D'ici là je vais un peu parler d'hypnose sur la chaîne, mais plutôt dans la deuxième partie de l'année, à partir du mois de septembre.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous a plu, si c'est le cas faites le nous savoir en laissant un petit
mais néanmoins très agréable...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
N'hésitez pas à nous laisser un commentaire, car je les lis tous et j'y réponds en fin de semaine. Généralement le dimanche ou le samedi.
Mais surtout parce que l'activité préférée de Céline Holynski est de lire vos commentaires. C'est vrai tu les lis souvent ?
-Oui, c'est un peu ma télé-réalité à moi. On trouve des petits gossips.
[rires] C'est vrai que parfois il y a des trucs chelous, des trucs drôles, des conversations...
-Des compliments aussi comme; "elle a un joli col Claudine..."
Tu sais que suite à cette phrase on va avoir; "mais c'est qui Claudine ?"
[rires]
N’hésitez donc pas à commenter et aussi de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir.
Car le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, donc rendez-vous demain à 11H, parce que demain c'est samedi.
Ciao !